c'est un truc qui est assez marrante
c'est assez incroyable et ça qui est
rigolo donc cet amour des salons on est
ici au mwc à barcelone et qu'est ce
qu'on voit quand on arrive et c'est déjà
on voit du du orange du range ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on est chez
oubliez ça c'est cool alors qu'est-ce
qui se passe mg alors là des smartphones
qui sont présents sur le stand et qui
n'ont pas encore été annoncés et ça
c'est cool parce que ça nous plaît on
aime bien voir naître un fol exclu alors
je vous fait vibrer voilà ce qui va se
passer là vous avez la gamme rennes me
not really not vous connaissez je vous
ai parlé du rémi notre onze on l'a testé
sur les sorties ont été annoncés mais
vous avez également leurs ennemis note
11 aces qui figure sur le site de chiens
ont mimé qu' on n'a pas encore pu avoir
vous avez également le pro 5 g vous avez
également le pro caggiano skier très
cool et bien c'est que on peut
comprendre la gamme donc on va dire ça
tout de suite on va bosser pour
comprendre la gamme de xiaomi au niveau
du lagane rémy note pour l'année 2020
des produits qui sont pas encore là mais
contestera plus tard alors aujourd'hui
l'idée c'est pas te faire un test loin
de là l'idée c'est de comprendre comment
s'articulent ses gammes et puis d'avoir
une vision un peu dans ce sens et que je
pense que ça vous aidera d'ailleurs si
vous voulez un smartphone pour faire
votre choix donc c'est une vidéo qui va
travailler en complément avec les vidéos
tests qui arriveront plus tard parce que
forcément les produits sont toujours pas
arrivés donc là on a une vision
d'ensemble et puis peut-être que plus
tard on fera une autre vidéo 2d stabilo
parce qu'on aime bien sacd et stabilo et
que vous savez que j'ai omis dans un
petit truc c'est qu'ils aiment bien nous
perdre dans les méandres de l'organe qui
est tellement large que bout d'un moment
c'est pour lui tout on en est donc on
regarde accrochez vous ça va être hyper
intéresse
premier smartphone qu'on va regarder 120
dont on a déjà parlé c'est leur ennemi
notons les bras on se regarde de plus
près comme ça sera méthane dont resituer
un petit peu ce produit dans la gamme
regardez déjà couleurs plus tomates à
l'arrière ça c'est un smartphone qui
commence à 199 euros ça permet de
rentrer dans la gamme aujourd'hui rémy
note sur un modèle de 2022 on va voir
quoi on va avoir des côtés qui sont
légèrement plat et pas trop bombay un
dock est très légèrement bombé bon ça
c'est un très grand classique un montant
qui est forcément un peu plus grand que
ce qu'on va avoir sur les autres bord
parce que fatalement on est quand même
dans le milieu de gamme de l'entrée de
gamme ou dans l'entrée de gamme du
milieu de gamme comme vous voulez alors
ici on a quoi ici on a un écran amoled
c'est du full hd + une diagonale de 6 43
pouces taux de rafraîchissement de 90 à
son pouvoir de la fluidité pour le
gaming pour venir naviguer ça c'est
plutôt pas mal côté performances à
atteindre agon 680 on a une grosse
batterie de 5,8 millions terreur la
charge 33 watts on a quatre capteurs à
l'arrière même si en un qui va être
vraiment intéressant ces quatre
principales de 50 méga pixels après vous
avez un ultra grand angle de 8
mégapixels la macro 2 et 1 14 profondeur
de autant dire qu'on s'en fiche un peu
c'est cela qui va nous intéresser pour
commencer à entrer dans la gamme rémy
note 199 euros la vidéo est déjà dispo
sur la chaîne dont vous pouvez y aller
je vous mets le lien quelque part par là
où aura bref la vidéo est sur ma chaîne
vous pouvez déjà voir le test comme ça
vous saurez tout sur smartphone donc ça
c'est le premier maintenant on va se
parler dans nos smartphones qui est de
l'autre côté la basse et leurs ennemis
note 11 aces et ne sais pas pourquoi s
mais il s'appelait alors on y va alors
c'est lui ça c'est le raid min 11 s
alors on a sensiblement le même design
que sur leurs ennemis note 11 fatalement
c'est une gamme un peu plat sur le
dessus mais plutôt plat l'idée du menton
l'idée de la face avant est bien c'est
la même chose l'arrière également est
très similaire il ya un modèle qui sera
un peu différent on va le regarder un
petit peu plus loin vous voyez on
appareils quatre caméras même module bon
bref si un rémy note c'est assez normal
ici on a une balle de 6 43 pouces c'est
du full hd plus on a également un tour
d'un fléchissement de 90 hertz un taux
d'échantillonnage tactile 280 est donc
ça pour le gaming c'est quand même
plutôt pas mal au niveau du proche on
reste indécis sur un processeur a4 j'ai
uniquement c1 médiathèque saint et
lioger 96 donc à la différence du raid
minott 11 qui est juste de l'autre côté
est bien ici on n'est pas chez qualcomm
on est chez mediatek mais avec les logis
96 on aura un point de plus de
performances qu'avec le rémi notre onze
on va avoir une grosse batterie de 5
millions en période toujours l'idée de
façon à sur les smartphones d'entrée
milieu de gamme c'est des grosses
batteries pour venir oui sur l'autonomie
mais ce qui est intéressant en plus ici
c'est qu'on a de la recharge rapide 30 3
watts exactement la même charge que sur
leur éminente 11 des haut parleurs
stéréo une prise jack ici la com sans
l'autre également la différence que vous
avez avec leurs ennemis note 11 c vous
allez voir ici + 2 mégapixels on est sur
un 100 8 mégapixels sinon le reste de la
config c'est la même 8 + 2 + 2 donc
cette partie en bas elle nous intéresse
pas des masses celle ci peut être plus
intéressante alors attention on n'est
pas chez sony on est ici sur un capteur
de samsung je pense que la qualité sera
quand même moins mais c'est normal une
fois plus en termes de tarifs c'est pas
non plus le smartphone le plus cher et
si le tarif est à 249 euros 90 voyez on
est quand même monté on a rajouté 50
euros pour avoir un capteur de 5
mégapixels et un peu plus de
performances mais on reste en quête x
qui nous emmène maintenant sur la gamme
pro la gamme prof d'abord un modèle 4g
est un modèle 5 g on va regarder la
différence ça se passe juste par là sur
le modèle prôné un design qui je trouve
un peu mieux fini est forcément plus
premium est ce que c'est parce que c'est
un modèle pro peut-être forcément il
sera plus cher alors on va retrouver un
côté très plat sur les côtés comme on
assure le reste de la gamme mais je
trouve que le dow est beaucoup moins
bombée beaucoup plus plat et ses
définitions que j'admire préféré alors
après au niveau du module photo bien on
est dans cette gamme art et demie notons
donc de toute façon ça va être
exactement la même chose d'un point de
vue extérieur à l'intérieur vous allez
voir c'est quand même relativement
différent et la différence surtout vous
allez avoir par rapport au rpt et demi
en 11 s et bien c'est qu'ici vous avez
un écran avec un taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 hertz on va
aller plus loin au niveau de
l'expérience au niveau de la fluidité
mais si on exactement le même processeur
que sur leur ennemi note 11 aces à
savoir un médiathèque 1 et lioger 96
donc en termes de performances avec la
même chose la différence vous aider il
ya le taux de rafraîchissement s'en va
ailleurs et puis surtout la diagonale de
l'écran qui va être plus grande on est
sur du 6,67 pouces de diagonale jour
full hd + taux d'échantillonnage tactile
360 r ça tu n'y a pas de changement
toujours une grosse batterie de 5
millions en perdre sauf que là on va
aller plus vite au niveau de la charge
avec un bloc de chage 67 soit menacée
d'une pro forcément on vous sa tartine
en hausse aille plus vite on aura la
même performance mais une meilleure
efficacité au niveau de la charge et
c'est exactement la même chose au niveau
de la photo que sur leurs ennemis notre
onze aces à savoir votre capteur
principal de son game & gas pixels signé
samsung et vous avez un triptyque en
dessous ultra-grand-angle 8 mégapixels
macro 2 mégapixels profondeur de 2
mégapixels donc ça de toute façon on a
vu que ça va changer dans la gamme donc
on va qu'en fait ce qui a vraiment
changé c'est que sur leurs ennemis notre
11 50 méga pixels dès que vous arrivez
sur le 11 aces et sur le pro 4g vous
avez votre capteur de 5 mégapixels mais
voilà peu pour l'histoire leur ennemi
notre onze pros 4g est annoncé au tarif
de 349 euros ok mais et c'est là où ils
sont malins ils aiment bien s'amuser
c'est que nos sorties également un
modèle professionnel mais 5 g il est là
mais bon le fmi note 3,5 g il va changer
de processeur pourquoi même parce qu'on
est sur un smartphone 5g donc qui lui
font un processeur qui puisse avoir un
modem 5 g c'est normal on est chez
qualcomm snapdragon
695 5 g gravure si nanomètres ok jusque
là c'est sympa on va rester sur une
batterie de 5 millions terreur et
toujours avec de la recharge 60 sites
web comme sur le modèle qui est 4g on
regarde la namibie en tout cas les
cramps et du 6,67 pouces taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 hertz toujours
un taux d'échantillonnage tactile 360
hertz full hd plus bien évidemment le
design va ça va resté la même chose on
est sur le modèle professionnel on est
plat l'arrière c'est beau c'est léger
c'est pas sur le côté j'aime beaucoup
ses finitions je trouve bien meilleur au
niveau des modèles pro que sur les
modèles qui sont pas pros c'est à dire
le 11 et le 11 aces et alors là c'est
l'accord igol parce que c'est quand même
le modèle le plus haut de gamme pour
autant on a un capteur à - salut mon
petit lapin ça va filmer la montre long
il est là ça va mon petit lapin d'amour
ça doit bien ce petit bec comme ça la
tonte image
est une question de finition dise où on
en fait le truc qui est marrant c'est je
vous dis on a un capteur principal de
100 8 mégapixels c'est le même en fait
qu'on va retrouver à partir du 11 aces
en allant jusqu'au 11 pro 5 g mais on a
un capteur à - on à un capteur en moins
c'est à dire qu'on n'a plus le triptyque
8 + 2 + 2 on a effectivement le 8 méga
pixels pour l'ultra grand temps qu'on
l'a on voit qu'on a ici on à cape town
macro de 2 mégapixels mais on a perdu le
capteur de profondeur de 2 mégapixels
donc on est dans le pro le plus haut de
gamme et on en perd un petit peu alors
de vous à moi je voulais dit pour moi le
capteur de profondeur 2 mégapixels ici
lucien globalement pas grand chose mais
ça reste surprenant que soit le modèle
le plus haut de gamme en 5 j ai bien on
ne l'est pas choix intéressant très
intéressant.moi ici j'ai pas réussi à
voir tarif on s'en doutera on sera à
plus de 350 euros bien évidemment mais
ça on en reparlera plus tard donc je
vous invite à faire une chose c'est bien
évidemment à vous abonner sept petits
boutons rouges qu'elle a si les rouges
c'est que vous n'êtes pas abonné puis
même si vous êtes abonné vous venez
actionner la cloche comme ça vous serez
notifié dès qu une prochaine vidéo
rivera dit qu'on parlera des chiots me
compare à nos marques comme ça c'est
plutôt bien donc si on reprend on
commence avec la gamme art et demi note
11 avec un capteur de 50 méga pixels et
on est chez qualcomm en 4g on continue
ensuite on monte on va chez mediatek sur
le 11 aces et sur le onze pros kg c'est
le même processeur sauf que là on a un
capteur principal de 100 8 mégapixels
donc une meilleure définition on verra
ça bien évidemment lors du test
ultérieurement sur le modèle
professionnel on arrive avec un écran
avec un taux de rafraîchissement de 120
hertz et puis après vous avez le modèle
le plus haut de gamme leur ennemi notre
aux pros 5 g on retourne chez qualcomm
avec un processeur 5 g avec le même
capteur sans 8 mégapixels ou on perd un
petit capteur de profondeur qui ne
servaient globalement à pas grand chose
et puis bien évidemment la charge d'un
monte on passe de la 33 watts jusqu'à la
67e watsa doit recharger plus vite vous
proposer quand même une gamme cohérente
alors moi cette gamme se trouve
intéressante j'aime bien cette gamme et
puis vous savez que c'est chez omis la
gamme raid me nots et la gamme dont ils
font le plus de volume au niveau des
ventes en réalité une marque comme si
robin tous les autres c'est pas sur le
plus haut de gamme c'est pas sur les
smartphones à 800 et 1000 euros qui vont
faire le plus de volume de vente c'est
sur le moyen de gamme entre et moyen de
gamme c'est sûr on est vraiment sur un
moyen de gamme qui est très sympa parce
que chez au mythe l'entrée de gamme
c'est la gagne rémy alors je sais y'a
rémy notre ennemi mais qui ne sont pas
du tout les mêmes gammes voilà donc
j'espère qu'ils ont réussi un petit peu
vous montrer un peu ce qui se dessine du
côté de chez orbit sur la gare et demi
note 11 en 2022 petit moi ce que vous en
pensez juste en bas en commentaire et
quant à nous on se retrouve très vite
pour continuer à parler de ses produits
à les tester et puis plein d'autres
parce qu'on est ici à barcelone au
mobile world congress il ya plein de
moments il n'y a pas de smartphone de
tous les côtés ça me rend dingue et
j'aime ça nous embrasse à bientôt
[Musique]